we know how much our fans love playing
fifa and we're excited to introduce the
xbox one FIFA 16 bundles both bundles
include FIFA 16 3 loan legends for your
ultimate team and EA access so you can
play fifa first on Xbox one the fifa
bundles are available starting September
15 and you can pre-order them today now
let's take a look at more of the games
coming in 2015 joining FIFA 16 in the
lineup is a franchise that launched the
original Xbox has defined multiplayer
expo on Xbox Live and serves as the
cornerstone of our first party portfolio
this is halo 5 guardians xbox one
exclusive
since just 85 days until launch indeed
super excited to get a little bit more
hands-on with everybody there you know a
games come gonna be good hear me as well
hey there hi Mandy Bravo daninsky former
pro hello coach and joining me today is
my European counterpart any sport shell
camp sir richard sims thanks brava as we
just saw the halo multiplayer legacy
continues to evolve in halo 5 Guardians
and today it's all about arena arena is
halos eSports focus for v4 mode with
even stats the intense mix at slayer and
objective games I'm sandy narita I think
this new map that we're unveiling right
now will be a top choice in tournament
play moving forward let's take a look at
coliseum which has everything that makes
a great competitive arena experience
it's a symmetrical to base map which
includes a unique mix of elevation and
sidelines and it's purposely built for a
wide variety of fast-paced multiplayer
modes now in anticipation of the halo 5
Guardians gamescom invitational
happening here at the ESL arena we
invited two of the top halo pro teams in
the world epsilon esports and optic
gaming to play some preliminary matches
at the 343 industries headquarters in
seattle let's talk a little bit about
these two teams em Bravo epsilon esports
is one of the best teams in all of
Europe very new care players including
the box wins but 57 and book 21 of the
whinnies jurors in European halo now
halo is predominantly been dominated by
the North American seem so the question
was can epsilon upset the balance and
change a compass needle and that's it on
the other side of the stage we have fan
favorites optic gaming from the u.s. led
by halo veteran flame sword and the
winner of the 2013 halo 4 global
championship ace now these two teams
have never played before so of course a
lot of speculation on the line of a who
would come away with the ultimate
victory and all of the cause of the
visit these two teams valve in
after match of intense competition may
Allah grounded up with the best of three
series on capture the flag on the new
map policy and i have to tell you since
i got a chance to see each and every one
of these matches and these two teams
were a neck-and-neck throughout the
entire series but it all came down to
one last game you know what let's jump
on bat and take a look at some of the
most closest moments of the final game
all right so we're gonna be checking out
for the first time ever coliseum in halo
5 guardians the game is going to be
capture the flag 3 captures to win or
the top scorer after 12 minutes our two
teams in red will be optic gaming the
end in blue it'll be epsilon esports
going to kick things off here with flame
sort off the brake but since one of the
first things you're going to notice RB
player outlines here halo 5 Guardians
has made some major investments in
eSports features and some of that is
getting players better camera and
specular tools to make sure they can
tell the best story they can during a
match take a look at this flame for
picks up the double kill and now we move
across at the moment is Jimbo coming
back on the defensive you know someone's
in the kid grenade goes in this process
if a sniper rifle this be a big kill
which he manages to get the flock is
there however he turns around spots many
are texting down big double kill and he
gets the mixer dismissed big plays from
Jim Ont but on the other side of the map
for Team Europe it's 120 grabbing the
second over she loved the game for his
squad epsilon esports he's going to use
that to push into the enemy base and
grab the first flag of the match take a
look at that on your screen flag
juggling has returned here in halo 5
Guardians as buck 20 s for South flag
all the way across the map and over
shield in hand it finally gets a little
bit of late pressure though as you round
this corner but in doing so Sims epsilon
esports will go up one to 0 with 10 20
left the match moving forward with book
20 again he's backing up six best and
just in their fists at it when she did
he fight us all a shield texting down no
problem goes to the second pole of this
match is caused by for a lil bit
offensive he threw us out and all of a
sudden we see play
so come out of nowhere he gets second
down it does come back for a little bit
of a defensive shot however the books
when he says no he's gonna run that
straight out the front bridge of the
moment Lucy you're moving forward text
the flag jumps Bruce toggles and he
manage to clamber up into the blue coat
yeah he's gonna run that forward however
he's gonna take some shots in the back
but that doesn't matter at all Jesse
teammates like John right behind him to
get the collection yes ye sports gonna
go up to 20 but let's take a look at
that replay right there slow it down in
it look at that jump tossed crust and
clamor using those brand-new smart
abilities to escort the flag all the way
across the map and epsilon esports will
secure that point and go up in the match
to 20 back on Barbra Jean bossy right
now growing some cracking shots across
the map money is to land their head shot
with the Magnum since we've left you're
gonna hit some defense there find this
grenade goes in Willie clean up this
hill EXT building d disease Bruce
surrounded go find the soul takes him
down another big double kill but Jimbo
if there's more in store for Jimbo here
take a look at this the over shield
power is about to drop here it comes
boom plans the Spartan charge stealing
the over shield out from underneath the
optic gaming setup sins we gotta run
that back one more time that over shield
power up so pivotal but look at this
Jimbo with four enemy players on his
screen he swoops in here landing that
perfectly time Spartan charge also uses
the thruster pack to grab the over
shield that's gonna have epsilon esports
continue their control of the bottom of
the map now back into the match in real
time you see cuz maniac is desperately
trying to shut down Jimbo some way
somehow he jumps up here but Jimbo will
then the punch to the face coming off
the spawn now we've been here he's gonna
get himself at the moment yes he does he
gets a punch himself John how she'll
take you down grab the snipe travel but
you know what bra but there's only woman
8 30 remaining in the game right he
needs to make something happen and he
needs to do it now which is exactly what
he doesn't going to run that should I
out the front page now looking for some
support from his teammates but
unfortunately he just grind Jimbo Jimbo
again with an uber defensive it's too
much deeper 00 in the
left quadrant of his map I'll take one
player out yes indeed spots a second
here on the second in assists there but
spots a third and uses the ground
pounced all the pressure from epsilon
esports is just too great we switch over
to book 20 in the last moments of the
match where the clock is ticking down
and epsilon esports will win the game to
20 and win the final series with a score
of three to one congratulations to
epsilon esports on that incredibly
clutch win here at sex this first round
showing the American scenes that they
have a little something to think about
how I think that is the case indeed
their sims I believe they have a little
bit to think about like you said North
America of course usually on top but
bragging rights weren't the only stakes
at these teams are playing for each
player on epsilon is walking away with
this limited edition halo 5 Guardians
Eve one terabyte Xbox one complete with
a matching controller a console that
will be available to the public
including the digital version of the
game on October 20th so the players can
pre download and be ready for battle on
day one and sams that console is
available for pre-order immediately
following briefing I think we all better
go home and get his pre autozone and
remember guys you can catch epsilon and
optic as well from the top European
teams on Friday for the halo 5 Guardians
gamescom Invitational 2015 on the halo
channel as well as twitch.tv /hello
that's right we hope you'll join us
before we go let me welcome to the stage
executive producer of halo 5 Guardians
josh holmes